it wasn't enough to make the new list
from Forbes magazine out the
highest-paid stars Taylor Swift came in
at very top not surprising but for those
who think Kim Kardashian is famous for
no reason well think again but you guys
think of Milan tonight for the cover we
really wanted a true business story and
that's what the story of Kim
Kardashian's mobile game please she's as
worthy as anybody else today Kim tweeted
the cover was a tremendous honor
followed by the hashtag not bad for a
girl with no talent back to the top 10
join tswift but still far off from her
170 million one direction author James
Patterson and dr. Phil and thanks to his
comedy tour Kevin Hart made it hugely
for last year's rank of 95 to come in at
number six becoming the first comedian
ever to out-earn Jerry Seinfeld after
being noticeably absent last year Adele
return number nine more than half about
18.5 million dollars of the sales of her
latest album and barely making the cut
Britney Spears at number 99 with a mere
30 point five million what one more note
Beyonce and jay-z are the highest
ranking couple not surprising there she
is 34 with 54 million he's right behind
a 36 with 50 3.5 million oh look at you
in just about just to love it some kind
say that is that all right
you